hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that includes a position you
guys keep sending me uh ever since elon
musk tweeted about it on twitter and uh
the so-called chuck mate now is it
possible and uh how would this game even
turn out now not so long ago i think it
was okay maybe two years ago some
somewhere during around christmas hikaru
nakamura gave uh
such odds to mr beast he defeated him
using only a king and the queen uh if
you remember uh this was the thumbnail
of the of the video so uh with the black
pieces just the king and queen and he
defeated mr beast who had all of his
pieces all of his pawns and everything
and even though uh you know mr beast
knows how to play chess it was
considered impossible that such a thing
could happen
now what would it take for someone to
win uh with only a pawn now of course
this position is an illegal one because
the white king is missing from the board
that's something that
whoever made this obviously didn't take
into consideration probably uh is not a
check uh chess player now they probably
wanted to emphasize how chuck norris was
all powerful and uh you know
something like that most likely i don't
know what the idea behind the tweet is
probably something to do with uh
elon buying twitter or not buying
twitter or or whatever but that's not
what we are here to discuss if anyone
knows what it's about to share in the
comments you know to increase everyone's
vast knowledge but we are here to
discuss the position uh is it possible
and what would happen so of course it's
not possible uh but uh it kind of is
possible uh let's say that there was a
king on the board or maybe the king was
close or cloaked or maybe somewhere on
the board let's say the king was uh
maybe you know here on e1 let's see
and uh would the position be playable
now because this position can occur i've
been in many bars and i've seen many
people play
and for example this one time i played
against a very strong player uh maybe
raided at the time i played him i was
rated maybe around 1500 he was rated
around 2000 and he already had a few
beers uh maybe you know three or three
or four a reason a reasonable amount of
beer for any person
and as you know we were just blitzing uh
the moves his king fell off the board
and he didn't realize it he was sitting
in his lap and you know he was thinking
about what to do and he couldn't figure
out a move because he couldn't make
plans there was no king on the board and
it just took him like forever to realize
this but okay uh just uh just a nice
story to throw in maybe uh that uh you
know it's possible to have a position
with only one king on the board if you
are you know playing in a bar for
example
uh but uh here let's say uh wha what uh
does this position bring us if the king
is let's say an e1 can white win this
and how bad would black have to play uh
for white to actually win this if it's
possible because uh mr beast lost to
hikaru with only a king and queen so
would it be possible for someone to
defeat uh
you know anyone uh who has full pieces
full pawns uh with only a king and the
pawn and of course so we don't have an
opponent so we are using mr hoodie guy i
hope you guys are wearing a hoodie as
well
and
i i found uh uh well
it can be done it can be done and it can
it can be done fairly quickly
uh for example if black wanted to win
this it's not a problem let's say white
would push the pawn black would block
the pawn and now we just bring a queen
and any piece into the game and we check
made the white king with the king to d1
uh sorry about that uh let's say queen
to d6 we're gonna bring the queen into
game it's the fastest way to checkmate
the white king with the king c1 queen to
h2 we cut off the white king from the
back rank and now we pretty much bring
any piece into the game we can even do
it with a knight like the king c1 knight
characters king here and now a nice
checkmate quincy to check we need to
checkmate it would take black seven
moves uh to checkmate white from this
position but how many moves would it
take white to checkmate black uh
if black did not play the absolute best
moves or maybe black was just you know
fooling around or maybe black was uh not
the greatest of players as you know such
people do exist
uh let's check it out this is what i've
come up with maybe you can come up with
something better or faster so d4 let's
say e5 uh giving up a pawn for rapid
development d captures on e5 and f6
giving up more material for rapid
development e captures on f6
knights the e7 uh hoping for pawn
captures knight and then we just
captured the knight and check made the
white king but now f captures on g7 and
now let's say black wants the you know
humiliated white for some reason or
black is just a
weird person uh would play h5 he wants
to march his pawn down the board and
bring another queen into the game
because sometimes when you really want
to humiliate your opponent you're just
going to bring you know 10 queens um
in the game and
of course not 10 you can't have 10 of
them but you can have 9 of them uh so
here let's say g captures an h8 you
could bring a queen into the game but
let's take a knight okay so we la we
grab a knight uh h4 black continues to
march his pawn down the board uh
promoted to to a queen knight to g6 we
have knight to b knight beat the c6 and
not knight to f4 guarding the h3 square
we have knight to e5 and now knight the
h5 and here
let's say knight to f7 and knight to f6
and this is now a beautiful smothered
mate
this is uh what i've come up with nine
moves uh is the
we can probably do it faster i didn't
really put much thought into this i just
wanted to answer your your question if
it's possible for white to win this of
course it's possible if you have a pawn
you have a chance or if you have any
peace there's always a chance with um
uh you know uh if black also has pieces
and pawns then a position can be
possible there are even uh exercises
that you can do uh if you if you've ever
heard of a self a self-made or help mate
it's it's a position where you have to
find moves and black uh has to help you
to checkmate
the black king and it's it's a it's a
really weird concept but for some reason
uh some people do it uh so this would be
one such example now it is possible of
course not from this position or it is
possible from this position if um
you know
you're playing in a bar and the white
king falls into your lap or something uh
but uh in in in a position where the
uh
white king is just nicely sitting on the
board it is of course possible to win
this with white if black does not have
perfect moves i was able to do it in
nine moves if you have a faster example
do post in the comments i will give it a
heart so everyone can see it is it
possible to checkmate black even faster
from this position uh so yeah a nice uh
a nice detour from uh from the current
events uh i hope you guys enjoyed this
as it is you know quite a quite a
question to answer
because some people might think that
this is impossible you can't play this
there's no way that you can win but in
chess you know if you have even one
point you can defeat your opponent if
your opponent isn't that um uh you know
amazing of a player uh so yeah that's
the game and the nice story hope you
guys enjoyed that uh i would like to
thank steven abrams nagarjuna ponogoti
david bacon uh rubbishing reptiles
youtube and gregory patelski for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check two of my previous videos
here thank you for watching and i will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the ftx uh uh crypto road to miami cup
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day
and as always a big congratulations to
everyone who watched this video wearing
a hoodie see you soon